you get that floppy wig
that's great you've been ziplining at
fremont street yeah i've been ziplining
on freemont street have you done that
yet i have not done that oh you gotta
add that to you i like heights i don't
mind the heights it's really fun okay
what are you doing tonight yeah yeah i
guess that might be a dinner break
activity i want to watch that and i
always wanted to do undercover boss with
the weather team oh oh well i don't
think that's gonna well i don't think
that's gonna work she's trying to
picture ted in that sweet early 70s
rocker wig he looks like a basis from
like an early seventies band i actually
like that look i want to go with that
one simon says hey guys i'm i'm fred
torrento
all right all right live
wait a second
not a very good undercover name that
sounds familiar there's no way that's
getting past sherry
[Laughter]
look outside right now
uh yeah i'm gonna catch that on cbs
that's gonna be a great episode i always
love undercover boss live look down the
strip
at uh resorts world cloudy skies outside
right now wind staying light that will
pick up tomorrow though 63 degrees our
official high for the day today so even
with the clouds we've managed to squeeze
63 degrees 44 overnight for the low 58
our average for this time of the year so
we're above average 73 the record set
back in 1945 but again look at the low
eight degrees the record low on this
date was the coldest las vegas has ever
been at least since they started taking
records back in 1937 so that's a big
number plus we always love number eight
55 in centennial hills right now 57 for
sky canyon 60 for spring valley 59 north
las vegas just still in the 60s for
sunrise manor same for whitney ranch 58
for henderson 56 southern highlands and
anthem right now you're at 56 degrees
outside of town 55 for currently in 52
boulder city 64
for laflin radar showing some echoes
coming back like we talked about but
again this is high level moisture still
too dry the dew point is only 23 degrees
near the surface right that's how dry it
is at the surface so this is hitting
that layer and then evaporating before
it's even reaching the ground so all
we're really seeing is just the cloud
cover other than the rain on the ground
valley radar zooming out though showing
you where the disturbances are there's
one up here in the pacific northwest and
this is the cutoff low we talked about
off of baja that's sending us those
clouds see that we'll see this one dive
down that'll clear the clouds out but
it'll do this it will increase our winds
winds for us for tomorrow look at all
the colors now firing up we'll have
double-digit wind speeds on friday and
saturday remember that lake wind
advisory goes into effect on friday at 9
00 a.m tonight 45 degrees overnight
still cloudy we'll keep it chilly 65 for
tomorrow a mix of sun and clouds sun in
the morning then clouds later on day and
like we said we will see those breezy
winds pick up we'll talk about how
strong those winds will get coming up in
our 8 news now forecast but for now your
8 day forecast showing temperatures
cooling off a little for the weekend
with clouds and then next week warming
back up to the mid 60s and no rain in
this eight day that is your most
accurate forecast 8 news now we'll be
right back